[Music]
all right tonight once again John
Solomon has a major breaking report this
time he's now exposing how fusion GPS
literally coordinated with Obama's
Justice Department all in the lead-up to
the 2016 election now remember fusion
GPS was the consulting firm it was hired
by the DNC and the Clinton campaign
they're the ones that dug up the dirt on
then candidate Trump that was full of
Russian lies and according to now newly
unearthed handwritten notes that we now
have senior Justice Department official
Bruce or he knew about Glenn Simpson's
effort to leak the dirty dossier to the
press prior to the election he wrote
quote it was Glenn's Hail Mary attempt
Hail Mary attempt of course to defeat
Trump with Hillary bought and paid for
Russian lies and it gets worse
now Bruce or also wrote the Glenn
Simpson gave him a memory stick during a
discreet meeting at a coffee shop by the
way where's that stick is it acid-washed
did they beat it up with a hammer now to
put this simply this new clear evidence
is showing Hillary Clinton's up research
team was working with the Department of
Justice in the Obama years to malign an
opposition party candidate and Bruce or
Barack Obama's number four at the DOJ
represented team Clinton's efforts to
use your government as a weapon against
the Trump campaign and as we speak the
House Judiciary Committee Chairman Bob
Goodlatte he is now preparing subpoenas
for Bruce or Nellie or Englan Simpson
and meanwhile we'll also learning new
details about Christopher steel and is
shady ties to a Russian oligarch Byron
York uncovered emails from 2016 showing
that Christopher Steele was in fact
lobbying on behalf of a Russia aluminum
tycoon well guess what with close ties
to Vladimir Putin Robert Muller
Jeff Sessions where are you people and
still even pressed Bruce or to help
rectify this Russian oligarchs US visa
status after he was already banned from
the unite
States and still even press Bruce or to
help rectify the oligarchs status and
after he was bad guess what he got to
come back so here what we have is an ex
foreign spy working for a Putin linked
oligarch gets him into the United States
after being banned by using his
connection the number four guy at the
DOJ during an election where Steele
being paid by killer II and the DNC they
literally using Russian lies and
propaganda they create the OP research
against the president then you have
fusion GPS then you have Christopher
steel disseminating that information to
influence the American people what are
outright lies because this is their Hail
Mary pass robert muller you have no
interest in investigating this you don't
think that's part of your mandate but
paul manna for its 2005 taxes that had
nothing to do with the campaign russia
trump or the election that's in your
mandate this is why we on this show
there's why the president rightly is
calling this a which on this is a
politically motivated prosecution of a
man they never wanted to be president
they were going to stop him and after
every dirty trick that they used to
defeat Donald Trump and it failed well
then they tried to destroy the president
why because you voted for him I could go
on and on but I think Rudy Giuliani said
it best last night right here on this
program take a look the reality is the
real story here is not that this case
isn't gonna fizzle it's gonna blow up on
them the real question is what we talked
about before there's a lot more to what
they did they nobody knows about yet I
know a lot more to the obstruction of
justice to the collusion to the Fate
dosti y know a lion of being sealed back
in after he was completely discredited
and then feed it to Muller yeah and
Muller is gonna have a lot to answer for
yes he does without a doubt this witch
hunt is the pinnacle of a two-tiered
system of justice alive and well in this
country the United States of America
Hillary Clinton commits multiple obvious
serious
felonies we've said it a million times
mishandling top-secret Intel on a
private server deleting it acid washing
it busting up devices with hard with
with hammers obstructing justice
she got a get-out-of-jail-free card from
her friends who wrote an exoneration
before investigation
call me struck and others and then you
have shifty shift remember we played it
he colluded on tape conspired on tape
with a Russian to get dirt on Donald
Trump
Robert Muller where are you meanwhile
President Trump all his allies they're
slammed with the full force weight of
the FBI and the DOJ based on what his
Clinton bought and paid for
Russian lies put together by his spy
who's friends with a Russian oligarch
and working on his behalf to get him
into the country after he's been kicked
out Paul Manafort Oh big case trial of
the century facing life in prison over a
2005 tax case on bank and tax charges
that had nothing to do with Trump Russia
or the campaign lieutenant general Flynn
coerced into a plea deal after a scope
Ettore evidence was withheld and then he
has to sell his house because he can't
afford to pay for his defense
and don't forget about even Carter page
2016 the FBI thought he was a Russian
spy and what did they do they use Steele
friend of the Russian oligarch his dirty
dossier that even he doesn't stand by he
doesn't even think it's true
misleading four separate FISA judges to
spy on a trump campaign associate this
is all happening you can't make this up
in a spy novel but was president Trump
was he ever notified by our federal
government that a possible spy might
have infiltrated his campaign so he can
help our government help the FBI not a
chance
meanwhile very different story plays out
if you're a Democrat by the name of
Senator Dianne Feinstein look at the
shocking revelations 2013 Feinstein
notified by the FBI one of her top aides
is investigated as a Chinese spy in
other words the FBI sought to protect
Feinstein not Trump perhaps because the
highest levels of the FBI are wrought
with anti Trump
bias and trying to take down the
candidate stop him with an insurance
policy of God forbid he does win not
senator Feinstein look night after
tonight on this program we are breaking
important news investigative reporting
I've said many times we're peeling back
the layers of corruption the biggest
abuse of power in our country's history
at the highest levels of our government
now that's not the case than the rest of
the news media let's take for example
conspiracy TV MSNBC you're gonna love
this tape now this is not the case
they're more interested in pushing
salacious rumors lies accusations Tom
Brokaw you spent your entire career this
is your NBC News and nowhere is this
more true than their chief conspiracy
theorist Rachel Maddow last night up to
her old tricks literally making
something out of nothing
whipping these left-wing viewers into a
frenzy over secret recording of the
house Intel Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez where he warned a roomful of
donors that if Republicans lose all deep
state investigations will be halted and
Democrats will try to impeach Trump
we've been saying this literally every
night on this program they also by the
way want open borders to eliminate ice
keep Obama care and they want the crumbs
back and of course making a big deal out
of nothing
well that's kind of their mo over there
at fake news MSNBC we can't forget about
their big scoop remember they've got one
page of Donald Trump's 2005 tax return
for 45 minutes we got it here it is it's
here and what did we discover he paid
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in taxes then of course there's
Rachel's favorite conspiracy that Trump
is in agent if the President did that
today because he has some reason to
serve that other country rather than our
own then well then a lot that has
previously been inexplicable is now
explicable is
our president subordinate to a foreign
power does our president answer to a
foreign government and a foreign leader
the worst case scenario that the
president is a foreign agent suddenly
feels very powerful what would change
the world is if you know Russia was
interfering in the election and they
weren't doing it on their own and he was
in on it I mean this guy supposedly
somebody who works at the Russian
central bank why did the FSB give him a
medal for his work a medal of
appreciation right after Donald Trump
clinched the Republican nomination for
president he's a foreign agent that's
why he's being so tough on Putin like
Obama wasn't and Clinton was it now if
you think her faked her overhype
so-called scoops flat-out conspiracy
theories in there well think again take
a look at this little wacky trip down
conspiracy lane I think you'll like it
of course Trump picked as a Secretary of
State not Mitt Romney but out of nowhere
the Exxon CEO Rex Tillerson to whom
Vladimir Putin had personally awarded
the Russian order of friendship tell her
soon as someone who Trump had never met
before the presidential election he'd
never had any dealings with where did he
come up with that as a choice for his
Secretary of State the perception that
the president may have ordered these
strikes in part because of scandal will
affect the impact and the effectiveness
of these military strikes unavoidably
they pulled their troops out starting
Friday September 29th which would be the
Friday after the Trump administration
made this baffling decision to insult
and harm our closest military ally in
that region those troops from Chad got
pulled out the 29th well right after
that
that's when four US Army soldiers got
attacked by a large contingent of Isis
fighters in the air Venezuelans are
enraged anew by this brand-new FEC
filing from the White House okay if you
think fake news couldn't get any worse
any more dramatic any more self-involved
you're forgetting about CNN's most
outspoken Trump hater
that's right BS Jim Acosta now he's
supposed to be an unbiased White House
correspondent but as we've shown you
many times all too often he uses his
hatred his contempt as left-wing agenda
for president Trump because he's
launching himself into a national
spotlight he's becoming a star last
night no exception
he tweeted out this picture of himself
look deeply into his own eyes just
before appearing on The Late Show with
fellow Trump hater Stephen Colbert take
a look these folks are focused on the
coverage of the president's behavior
more so than they are the president's
behavior and to me you know I think that
the president's behavior is more
newsworthy than our coverage but a lot
of these folks out there they're getting
their their sense of what we do twisted
and warped by some people out there who
just want to do the president's bidding
do you worry that the president points
at y'all so much and that there's a
natural need to respond as a human being
that you end up being the story when
that's not really the goal of of your
journalism right and we're not supposed
to be the story you know that's that's
not why I'm out there you know I get
accused of that from time to time and
and my attitude is listen I'm I'm
allowed to care about this country just
as much as anybody else when you corrupt
when you lie when you're nothing but an
extension of the Democratic Party yeah
you're gonna get called out by the way
the picture was so bizarre and Acosta's
constant flirtation with fame over
actual journalism is so obvious that
even some of his peers in the mainstream
media they're beginning to notice on
Tuesday the Atlantic referred to a
Kostas conduct as a dangerous brand of
performance German journalism meanwhile
frequent guests on fake news CNN
conspiracy TV MSNBC filmmaker Michael
Moore's coming out with a new
documentary he refers to Trump
the last president in the United States
is gonna be a coup gonna be bad what's
the perfect example of pre-election
left-wing lunacy how did this happen
the American Dream is dead
the President's powers here are beyond
collection
ladies and gentlemen the last President
of the United States
[Music]
scary music the worst picture you can
find all the special effects the
president's success is really starting
to throw these people over the ledge so
by the way Michael Moore if you're
watching cover your eyes you're not
gonna like what I'm about to show few
Research Center Trump voters
overwhelmingly approve of the choice for
president